hey guys I'm Mary and it's Thursday july
twenty eighth and it's a bit of a slow
news day but don't you worry we're gonna
splice in footage of Dark Souls with all
the textures being replaced with weird
stuff it's going to be just like first
up Darksiders is coming to pc xbox one
ps4 and wii u with a fresh coat of paint
Darksiders is getting remastered called
Darksiders war mastered edition the game
is coming to ps4 xbox one wii u and pc
or mastered edition improves upon the
original 2010 action-adventure game in a
number of ways for instance it's going
to run at a native 1080p on consoles it
also hits 60 frames per second on ps4
and xbox one although Wii U is limited
to 30 frames per second pc version
includes 4k support and additional video
option oh I can't wait to find out what
those are the changes also include
doubled texture resolutions ah rendering
improvements in rework ah Darksiders war
mastered edition releases on october
25th for twenty bucks not a fan of
darksiders don't leave here's dark souls
with all the textures replaced with
shrek
it should be no surprise to you that
apple sold a crap ton of phones but
yesterday they officially sold a butt
ton 1 billion but ton iPhones crossed a
milestone that's pretty impressive even
for iPhone Apple announced that its
recently sold the billionth iPhone the
iPhone first launched in 2007 and since
then there's been new models released
every year most recent models the iphone
6 and 6s plus set records upon their
release last year but this one well
that's a whole nother type of milestone
great job Apple here's dark souls with
all the textures replaced with crab
finally capcom sales and profits fell
due to lack of major releases capcom has
released its financial results for the
three month period spanning april first
through june thirtieth and they weren't
that great sales for the period were
cited as a hundred and four million
which is a twenty-four percent decline
when compared to the same period in 2015
operating income also fell and as a
result capcom took a 6.9 million loss
this operating income loss was due to
foreign exchange losses caused by the
rapidly rising yen according to capcom
but this was also cited by nintendo as
an issue in their latest financial
report capcom highlighted increased
development as a contributing factor to
the decline in profits but that's great
it probably means they're referring to
resident evil 7 and maybe some other
secret projects that are in the works in
their statements phoenix wright ace
attorney spirit of justice was said to
be selling largely as planned although
umbrella core for ps4 and pc was
mentioned as launched details of its
performance were not provided here's
hoping capcom can release some larger
titles towards the end of this year
here's every texture in Dark Souls
replaced with Nicholas Cage
Oh
so that's all I have for you today but
i'll see you again tomorrow for the top
five news stories of the week I'll see
them but until then here's a few more
Dark Souls textures to tide you over